The Disney Universe has you covered for your
favorite films and that’s because they acquired
Star Wars, The Muppets, Marvel Comics and
Pixar all within the last few decades. Their
universe is large and this means there are
a lot of Easter eggs for us to find. We have
picked out ten that will surely get you to
pay closer attention to the Disney Universe
and spark your interest in spotting your own.
Stick around to find out how a hidden Mickey
was put in a Muppet film.
Don’t forget to subscribe and join the notification
squad for cool content like this everyday.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Easter
Eggs In The Disney Universe That Will Blow
Your Mind.
Rey’s Helmet in Star Wars: Episode VII – The
Force Awakens
When The Force Awakens first hit theaters
fans immediately saw the X-Wing fighter pilot
doll in Rey’s home, but in another scene
she places an old rebel helmet on her head.
The Helmet has the Star Wars Aurebesh letters
“Resh,” “Enth,” and “Herf” on
the side of it and when translated into English
spells, R , AE, H; which is pronounced Rey.
Don’t get excited, this doesn’t mean Rey
was a fighter pilot because the markings on
the helmet mean it is from the Tierfon Yellow
Aces, specifically Captain Dosmit Raeh, a
female X-Wing pilot. All of this just from
a helmet!
Bomb Voyage in Ratatouille
Bomb Voyage is a criminal mastermind in the
movie The Incredibles and he even escapes
Mr. Incredible’s criminal fighting grips.
Sure it’s because of the interference of
a young Buddy but Mr. Voyage keeps that off
his resume. Another item he keeps off his
resume is his work as a mime in France. In
the movie Ratatouille when Linguini and Colette
are roller-skating by Notre Dame he can be
scene in the background performing. Maybe
this was a disguise for a plot to blow up
a famous landmark or a failed career move.
Alyssa Milano in Guardians of the Galaxy
There are many references to 1980’s paraphernalia
in the film Guardians of the Galaxy including
the popular troll doll and a very famous alien.
This is not an alien from that galaxy but
a cat-eating alien from the 1980’s sitcom
Alf. Another nod to the 80’s goes back to
Quill’s childhood crush, Alyssa Milano.
He named his starship the Milano after her,
looks like after all those relationships with
aliens, Star-Lord still has a place in his
heart for the Who’s the Boss? star and so
do we.
WALL-E in Finding Dory
Hank became one of the fan favorite characters
in Finding Dory and if you have seen the film
you know why. Another fan favorite character
is WALL-E from the 2008 film with the same
name. If Pixar can figure out a way to make
a spinoff film with Hank and WALL-E, we would
be thrilled but until then we will only have
one scene. In Finding Dory, when Hank has
Dory suspended over a massive aquarium in
a plastic cup you can see a WALL-E calendar
in the background. Maybe WALL-E units were
just being built during this time and 700
years later his story will pick up again.
Pingo Doce in Ant-Man
In the 2008 film The Incredible Hulk, Doctor
Bruce Banner works at a bottling factory in
Rocinha, Rio de Janeiro in Brazil, while searching
for a cure for his condition. He cuts his
finger and a drop of his blood goes into the
bottle killing a very recognizable elderly
man in Milwaukee, Wisconsin. This is how General
Thunderbolt Ross finds his location and hunts
him down. In the film Ant-Man, when Scott
Lang walks in the streets of San Francisco
you can see faded posters for the guarana
soda but where is the warning label?
Luxo Ball in Inside Out
The Luzo Ball was in Pixars first short film
and can be seen in every Pixar feature length
movie since. Some of the spottings are obvious
like in Toy Story but others are hard to spot,
one in particular is in the film Inside Out.
When Riley is playing with her imaginary friend,
Bing Bong they run right past the pall in
the corner. Also, remember how Bing Bong is
part dolphin? Check out the dolphin drawing
Riley is working on.
Big Hero 6 in Avengers: Age of Ultron
As Tony Stark prepares to head off into the
final battle against Ultron and the Ultron
army he is left without JARVIS to aid him.
So he shifts through a collection of AI programs
that he has created over the years. In the
end he chooses Friday, a female-voiced colleague
but look at the other choices he had. One
is labeled JACOSTA, which is a robot Ultron
creates in the comics and another is labeled
TACASHI. Tadashi is the name of Hiro Hamada's
older brother, who created Baymax in Big Hero
6.
Iron Giant in The Incredibles
Elastigirl helps director Brad Bird drop an
Easter Egg to an animated film that wasn’t
even made by Disney. Bird is the director
of The Incredibles and the director of the
Warner Brothers animated film Iron Giant;
both critically acclaimed films. When Elastigirl
flies in a plane she identifies her plane
to the radio tower. It stands for I G 99,
which also stands for Iron Giant, 1999. The
year Bird’s film was released.
Cars 2 in The Muppets
In 2004 Disney purchased the Muppets intellectual
properties from the Jim Henson Company giving
them the opportunity to make their own Muppet
films. Then in 2011 they did just that with
their musical comedy The Muppets. At the end
of the film when the stars and a great deal
of extras perform a song and dance routine
on Hollywood Blvd there is a billboard for
Cars 2. If that wasn’t enough checkout the
hidden Mickey in the fireworks! Looks like
Crazy Harry used his pyrotechnic skills for
brand promoting.
Vision in Captain America: Civil War
The Infinity Gauntlet is given its unlimited
power by having all six infinity stones in
the MCU. One of these stones is named the
mind stone; the powers of this stone are near
limitless psychic abilities including telepathy
and telekinesis. If you look closely to Vision’s
head in Captain America: Civil War you will
notice he wears the stone on his forehead.
This is bad news for vision since Thanos will
stop at nothing to acquire all six stones
and complete his Gauntlet.
There you have it ten Easter Eggs In The Disney
Universe That Will Blow Your Mind. Don’t
forget to subscribe to Screen Rant for more
fun videos. Thanks for watching.